et bonjour carole delga merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
présidente socialiste de la région de
sita ni présidente de région de france
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par julien écuyers de la voix
du nord aujourd'hui bien bonjour orient
bonjour madame de l'ua bonjour karl
zelda on va commencer en parlant de
cette nouvelle grève aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation nationale à l'appel des
syndicats elle s'annonce toutefois moins
suivie que celle de jeudi dernier mais
quand même est ce que pour vous c'est le
bon moyen d'action de la part des
enseignants on sait que la période
actuelle est compliquée pour les
enseignants mais aussi pour les élèves
et leurs parents la période en effet
elle est compliquée mais comme je
voudrais rappeler que les enseignantes
depuis 10 ans deux enfants quand même
des efforts très importants nous sommes
un des seuls pays dans le monde qui
avons réussi à maintenir l'école ouverte
au maximum et c'est grâce à la
mobilisation de nos enseignants et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une exaspération il ya une
fatigue la lassitude qui est très très
forte avec ce protocole sanitaire qui a
été changée tous les 48 heures est leur
seul moyen aujourd'hui d'être entendu
c'est la grève à l'ouverture excusez moi
même d'aller à l'ouverture des écoles
est ce que c'est pas m à mettre au
bénéfice aussi du gouvernement c'est à
mettre au bénéfice mais sur du
gouvernement mais quand même avant tout
de l'implication des enseignants parce
que moi je suis toujours un contact avec
le terrain et je peux vous assurer que
quand il ya eu le confinement complet
les enseignantes qui amenait eux mêmes
des cours aux élèves qui faisait
vraiment un suivi individualisé pour ce
qui était le plus en difficulté il faut
quand même savoir le rappeler donc
arrêtons de désespérer les enseignants
donnent l'heure des consignes claires
nous conservons il désespère les
enseignants avec ce protocole est quand
même qui était très complexe qui a été
envoyé quand même le dimanche soir pour
le lendemain pour les parents que je
pense aussi aux parents d'élèves c'est
incroyable cette cacophonie et on a
besoin dans un pays d'avoir une
éducation nationale qui soit forte parce
que c'est ce qui permet de lutter contre
cette crainte du déclassement qui existe
dans notre pays cette valse hésitation
du gouvernement sur le protocole dans
les établissements scolaires est ce que
cette à mettre déficit de jean michel
blanquer celui-ci doit-il démissionner
aujourd'hui écoutez je pense que là nous
sommes dans une situation qui est très
complexe avec encore un niveau de
contamination très fort il dort on doit
être tous mobilisés il faut arrêter les
attaques personnelles il faut demander
au ministre 2,1 à leur travail qu'ils
ont fait leur travail et c'est à dire
que jean michel blanquer soit concentré
sur sa mission et qu'il soit à l'écouté
des enseignants des parents d'élèves et
des élèves c'est ce qu'il faut mettre
vraiment en oeuvre et arrêtons d'être
encore la confiance des enseignants
ajouté aujourd'hui nous sommes à 80
jours d'une échéance présidentielle donc
pensons à l'intérêt des élèves
l'éducation nationale c'est un pilier de
la république aujourd'hui c'est quoi le
problème dans ce pays c'est que quand on
est enfant d'un milieu modeste on n'a
pas les mêmes chances d'accéder à des
études universitaires ya quatre fois
plus d'enfants de cadres que d'enfants
d'ouvriers dans l'université
l'orientation scolaire c'est un magma
c'est une jungle et c'est cela qu'il
faut mettre en oeuvre c'est l'escalier
de la réussite - en occitanie je fourni
l'ensemble et manuels scolaires
l'ensemble des ordinateurs des
ressources numériques depuis maintenant
quatre ans au lycée cela on doit donner
l'égalité des chances et c'est ce que
nous devons faire pour l'éducation
nationale qui est le même meilleur moyen
pour lutter contre la montée des
populismes et pour permettre à chacun
d'avoir son destin on parle de la crise
sanitaire madame délicat mais
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle est la
situation dans votre région occitanie
l'ordre dans notre région occitanie nous
allons avoir un pic sanitaire qui va
être légèrement décalée par rapport à
paris donc des contaminations qui vont
être fortes encore pendant quelques
jours et puis ensuite vient y avoir une
décrue mais moi je compte des hôpitaux
qui arrive à absorber la banque
aujourd'hui il y arrive avec un effort
remarquable el-hout aussi je tiens à
saluer l'engagement des professionnels
de santé avec un engagement remarquable
des professionnels de santé l'hôpital
tienne mais l'hôpital est en grande
souffrance et moi je demandais à mes
concitoyens de se faire vacciner de
respecter les gestes barrière c'est
absolument indispensable la bataille
n'est pas à gagner et on doit continuer
à être tous mobilisés vigier la bataille
est ce qu'elle va consister aussi dans
les prochaines dans les prochains mois à
revoir la façon dont est gérée la
coordination sanitaire est ce que les
régions de france vont plaider pour une
décentralisation des compétences santé
oui les régions de france plaide pour
une décentralisation des compétences
santé mais aussi les départements
également les maires aussi on a vu un
effet que au niveau de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire il y avait une trop
grande centralisation une déconnexion
complète c'est bien sur l'illustration
des masques mais c'est encore un manque
de réactivité du ministère de la santé
et donc il faut repenser complètement
l'action de l'état l'état doit être
concentrée sur ses à mission régalienne
et ensuite il faut donner plus de
pouvoir aux régions dans le cadre qui
doit être le gfc que par exemple
l'association des maires de france il
plaide pour que ce soit le préfet qui
qui mène là danse et que le
fonctionnement d aérer soit complètement
revu mais nous sur le fonctionnement des
drs nous 2 900 agences régionales de
santé nous demande nous demandons ce qui
est une co présidence et que les
présidentes et les présidents de région
puisse vraiment coprésider que les
régions puissent investir dans les
hôpitaux locaux parce que il y a un
besoin fort d'investissement dans ces
hôpitaux qui maillent le territoire et
puis également qu'on est les régions la
responsabilité des places de formation
pour les professionnels de santé et
supprimer réellement le numerus clausus
et qu'ensuite ce soit les régions qui
décident de nombre de places pour former
les kinés les aides soignants ainsi de
suite aujourd'hui on est limité de façon
très arbitraire par le ministère de la
santé c'est beaucoup trop décentralisons
vos mesures concrètes pour lutter contre
la désertification médicale concrètement
en occitanie c'est la région qui va
recruter des médecins j'ai lancé cela
les médecins salariés
donc dès le mois de juillet dès le
lendemain de mon élection nous avons mis
en place cette mesure est donc là sur
l'année 2022 nous allons recruter 40
médecins les premiers vont arriver en
juillet sur le terrain et ce sera donc
19 communes qui sont concernés des
communes où la démographie médicale est
en grande souffrance mais nous
travaillons aussi avec des villes dans
des quartiers où il y est nécessaire ont
également de mettre des médecins qu'est
ce que vous pensez de
l'incitation voire même de l'obligation
pour les médecins d'aller dans des
régions qui sont sous dotées je soutiens
le pr la proposition de loi de guillaume
garot on doit à vous ouah en fait un
conventionnement qui incitatif pour
aller dans des territoires qui sont sous
dotées on ne peut pas continuer à
fonctionner comme cela parce que quand
on voit qu'il faut 10 jours pour avoir
un rendez vous avec un médecin
généraliste dans certains territoires
c'est un sentiment vraiment de
déclassement pour la population c'est
une inquiétude et on doit savoir
répondre de façon concrète et les
régions l oms émission de pouvoir
recruter des médecins comme ça il n'y a
pas de concurrence entre les territoires
et on amène un service à la population
il ya aussi des difficultés à recruter
des soignants
il ya des postes qui ont du mal à être
pour vous est ce que la région peut
faire quelque chose à ce que vous pouvez
aussi recruter des soignants on peut on
peut recruter bien sûr des soignants
mais ce que nous devons vraiment
augmenté c'est le nombre de places de
formation je le dis moi j'ai encore
demandé l'année dernière en 2021 de
d'augmenter les places de formation et
de les financer et ça m'a été refusé par
le gouvernement on marche sur la tête
donc on est encore dans une gestion trop
peu décentralisés là pas de leçons de la
crise qui ont été tirées ce
qu'aujourd'hui dans la vague épidémique
on connaît vous dites que les choses se
passent bien entre l'état et les régions
c'est encore très compliqué non mais
c'est encore très compliqué ce qui est
très préoccupant c'est que on voit bien
de cette échéance présidentielle on ne
parle pas assez des vrais problèmes des
français et la décentralisation
c'est plus de pouvoir localement ces
thèmes des moyens de répondre à la
problématique des français d'ailleurs
d'avoir des décisions plus rapides les
françaises et français sont excédés des
délais des complexités administratives
et des réponses aussi différencier donc
il faut qu' il y ait vraiment une
nouvelle décentralisation c'est pas une
nouvelle étape si une nouvelle
conception de la décentralisation ou les
régions doivent avoir beaucoup plus de
pouvoir sur la question de l'orientation
scolaire sur les questions de santé et
aussi avoir vraiment une aide aux
entreprises qui soit beaucoup mieux
coordonner les régions nous sommes sur
le terrain nous sommes apportées
d'engueulades et surtout on sait faire
du sur mesure et on va parler de
l'actualité hier c'était le discours des
manuels mâcon devant parlement européen
guy discours qui qui a
comment dire montrer un débat très
franco français qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé vous même du discours du président
de la république devant le parlement
européen tout d'abord ce que je voudrais
dire c'est l'image qu'a donnée la france
hier était terrible moi j'aime quand la
france elle est grande et là on a eu un
discours du président de la république
qui était assez vide mais surtout on a
eu un débat un prêt débat présidentiel
ce n'était pas le lieu mais la fota qui
osent opposition au début d'ailleurs
montré en france un board en mai tout
d'abord emmanuel macron il aurait dû
demander le report de la présidence
française on ne prend pas une présidence
aussi importante pour l'avenir de
l'europe en pleine échéance
présidentielle parce qu'en termes clairs
sur les six mois emmanuel macron il aura
au maximum deux mois de plein pouvoir
c'est à dire on rate une chance
historique de transformer l'europe de
pouvoir lui donner les moyens d'aller
vers une europe qui s'occupe vraiment
été une vraie politique sanitaire en
particulier sur la question de la
recherche et des vaccins une robe aussi
qui a des vraies actions par rapport à
la question migratoire et puis une
europe du progrès c'est à dire avec
beaucoup plus d'investissements dans la
recherche de l'innovation et aussi dans
les grands travaux nous devons relancer
cette politique des grands travaux que
ce soit sur les infrastructures de
transport que ce soit aussi sur la
question du numérique parce que à
travers la politique des grands travaux
ça bien sûr un effet économique on élève
les pays le pib mais on élève aussi la
fierté des françaises et des français
des européennes parce qu'aujourd'hui on
voit bien nous avons une population un
peuple qui est dans la crainte et c'est
pourquoi il ya une montée des populistes
et moi je suis vraiment très déçu de
voir que ce rendez vous entre la france
et l'europe ne va pas pouvoir se
dérouler et hier on a assisté à un
moment qui était lamentable pour l'image
de la france pour son énergie en europe
et moi vous visez qui vous visent et
d'énigmes ado manon aubry qui qui se
sont opposés tous des bleus finalement
d'abord aulas le mélange des genres ça
aboutit à confusion quand on est à
quelques semaines d'une échéance
présidentielle on ne me prend pas la
présidence au niveau européen donc tout
d'abord emmanuel macron aurait dû
demander un décalage donc de six mois de
cette prise de fonction et employés là
il n'y a pas que la france inquiète
enjeu est ce que le problème de l' et
décale c'est qu'il ya un autre pays
aussi dédouané mais ça c'est déjà fait
nommer ça c'est déjà fait m'excuse de
vous le rappeler d'autres pays on
demandait le décalage parce que quand
vous faites le mélange des genres d'une
action pour l'europe et d'une campagne
présidentielle mais vous arrivez à cette
cacophonie où le président de la
république n'est plus président de la
république n'est plus président pour
cette fonction européenne et où ils
deviennent le candidat attaqué par
d'autres candidats et là je peux vous
assurer c'est mauvais pour la france et
moi je suis attaché à mon pays à sa
grandeur et surtout à ce qu'elle soit un
moteur la france pour la construction
européenne et pour qu'on ait une europe
qui soit plus protectrice et qui soit
aussi plus audacieuse dans la question
sur ce sujet oui est-ce que vous avez
publié vous même une tribune dimanche
dans le journal du dimanche sur
strasbourg coeur bâton de l'europe à ce
que emmanuel macron défense suffisamment
ce siège du parlement mais si nous
l'avons fait avec jean rottner président
de région grand testé avec renaud
muselier est président de la région sud
paca c'est que nous avons jugé que le
président de la république ne faisait
pas assez et donc nous lui demandons
d'être beaucoup plus impliqué sur le
fait que strasbourg continue à être
reconnus comme moteurs de la
construction européenne ya un sujet qui
inquiète les français c'est la hausse
des prix est notamment la hausse des
prix du carburant comment on y répond
selon voit cette hausse des prix ma
proposition comme celle d'ailleurs
d'anne hidalgo c'est bien sûr de baisser
la tva sur la question de l'essence et
du diesel sur le terrain'' moi ce
week-end tout le monde me parlait de la
problématique du plein c'est ça le vrai
sujet des françaises et des français
aujourd'hui il reste de moins
d'argent pour vivre aux françaises et
aux français avec l'explosion des
dépenses d'énergie avec cette question
vraiment du prix de l'essence qui
augmente vous rendez compte que nous
sommes sur des tarifs en particulier sur
par exemple la région parisienne ou dans
les grandes villes qui avoisine les 2
euros qui c'est qui peut avoir cette
agence cet argent là la problématique de
la fin du mois elle devient prégnante on
parle de on parle du plein mais on parle
aussi du prix du gaz puisque savez gérer
avec le prix de l'énergie va
exactement prix de l'énergie alors
gouvernement a t-il raison de mettre
pression sur edf pour contenir la hausse
des prix oui il a bien sûr raison mais
c'est un sujet qu'il va falloir quand
même fortement anticipée on ne peut pas
continuer à être avec des mesurettes
avec des chèques énergie qui tangue ils
sont versés ne compense même pas le
tiers de l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie il faut avoir une action
sociale forte sur les salaires il faut
augmenter les salaires parce que nous
sentons une vraie désespérance pour
celles et ceux qui travaillent et qui
n'arrive pas à finir la fin de mois le
travail doit être rémunérateur et ça
c'est un sujet qui est fondamental là le
chef de l'état en début de semaine
inventé l'attractivité de la france est
son bilan en matière de
réindustrialisation et un dossier qui
est symbolique dans votre région
s'essuie de l'assam dans l'aveyron cette
entreprise qui a été placée en
liquidation judiciaire lâché par renault
il ya plus de 300 salariés qui sont
concernés aujourd'hui où en êtes vous
sur ce dossier est ce que vous
travaillez avec l'état est ce que vous
êtes encore en discussion oui je
travaille avec l'état et nous y avons
encore à travailler mardi soir avec jean
castex alors tout d'abord pour trouver
un avenir industriel sur le site de
lassac parce que je le rappelle c'est
une fonderie nous avons besoin pour
notre souveraineté industrielle
française d'avoir une fonderie donc là
je travaille pour trouver un repreneur
sur ce secteur de la fonderie et puis
également travaillé ça mais c'est encore
possible c'est encore possible je ne dis
pas que c'est fait parce que c'est un
dossier complexe c'est en fait une
activité qui est très capitalistique la
fonderie dont qui demande de lourds
investissements avec des marges assez
faible mais c'est possible mais surtout
c'est indispensable pour la souveraineté
industrielle française et puis je
travaille également pour qu'il y ait un
développement d'autres entreprises sur
le secteur de decazeville donc sur ce
qu'on appelle le bassin avec le
développement du recyclage de batteries
électriques c'est qu'avec la snam où la
région est actionnaire parce que moi je
crois au volontarisme politique et à
l'action c'est-à-dire la région est
actionnaire de cette entreprise pour le
recyclage de batteries électriques c'est
bon pour l'emploi c'est bon pour
l'environnement et puis bien sûr
soutenir la filière aéronautique qui est
à proximité à une trentaine de
kilomètres ou pas ce qu'il y à une
reprise et nous faisons en sorte
vraiment de soutenir même si la
déclaration d' emmanuel macron à ce que
l'état ait suffisamment ce que vos côtés
sur ce sujet sur ce dossier mais il a
fallu que j'alerte en direct le premier
ministre pour qu'il y ait une meilleure
mobilisation que ces dernières semaines
parce que je sentais l'état qui était
juste sur les questions de reclassement
et qu' abandonner la question le projet
industriel et ses geôliers et
sensibiliser de l'agent castex donc m'a
donné a en effet des indicateurs ça veut
dire aujourd'hui avec 47 aujourd'hui il
ya des encouragements de la part du
premier ministre sur ce sujet je vous le
dis mais pourtant une question très fin
très factuelle et ce qui est ce qu'il
faut continuer de perfuser cesser ces
filières l'âge mais parce que ça pose
une question autour de la révolution
électrique qui est attendu dans le
domaine de l'automobile et beaucoup de
fonderie vont se retrouver dans la même
situation que sam est ce que il ne faut
pas surtout travailler à la
reconstruction de nouvelles de nouvelles
files et filières et de préparer cela il
faut faire les deux c'est à dire d'un
côté il faut faire en sorte qu'on ait
une souveraineté industrielle et qu'on
ait encore des fonderie parce que un
effet la fonderie sierre pour la filière
automobile mais pas que et ensuite ce
n'est pas de la perfusion que je propose
pour le projet de reprise industrielle
de l'assam c'est à dire c'est un ou
projets qui demandent de les deux
premières années de pouvoir être aidées
mais après qui trouve son équilibre
économique moi je ne suis pas là pour
gaspiller de l'argent public pour des
chimères moi je suis là pour aider dans
un moment difficile une entreprise et
lui permettre de se rétablir et après
d'avoir modèle économique rentable et il
faut en même temps que vous avez raison
aller vers la diversification c'est pour
ça que je vous parle de l'économie
circulaire avec le recyclage c'est pour
ça que je vous parle de l'aéronautique
avec l'avion plus vert avec l'avion plus
électrique et qu'on travaille aussi avec
nous notre pays pour pouvoir développer
l'électromobilité nous devons être sur
les technologies d'avenir mais nous ne
devons pas abandonner l'industrie
traditionnelle qui doit se reconfigurer
mais nous en avons besoin parce que
sinon nous allons avoir des pièces qui
vont être fabriqués à l'autre bout de la
planète et ça va être un problème de
compétitivité et aussi l'environnement
on verra quelques questions sur la
présidentielle pour kiev oui alors qui a
été très riche encore en événements on
du côté de la deûle à gauche avec une
candidature de christiane taubira un
retrait d'un je parle de la gauche ne
sais pas s'il faut le placer là mais
arnaud montebourg qui est donc ce a
annoncé son retrait d' hier qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette dernière
décision d'arnaud montebourg c'était
légitime c'était souhaitable c'était
inéluctable
je lui avais dit je suis ami avec arnaud
montebourg lui qui m'avait parlé de son
projet de se présenter à la présidence
de la république cet été je lis avait
indiqué que malgré tout la mythique que
j'avais pour lui je ne le soutiendrai
pas et que je pensais que c'était une
mauvaise idée donc arrive ce qui devait
arriver il se retire c'est dommage parce
que ça donne une impression terrible de
cacophonie pour la gauche et on voit
bien à travers les sondages que cela
désespère notre électorat puisque le
total gauche étant inférieure à 25% donc
à un moment la division eh bien elle
donne de la décrédibilisation au projet
de la gauche durable elle favorise cette
division christiane taubira c'est une
candidate de plus en effet et ça a été
une grande ministre de
la justice j'ai inauguré j'ai réouvert
avec elle le tribunal de grande instance
du comminges mon territoire natal mais
pour autant là elles n'apportent pas une
capacité d'union est la seule qui a la
stature d'être présidente de la
république c'est anne hidalgo et c'est
pourquoi je la soutiens vous y croyez à
ça se voit dans les sondages tout à fait
mais je suis lucide sur ces sondages
mais je continue à dire qu'à gauche la
seule qui a la stature l'expérience la
solidité morale et aussi la vision
internationale derrière sinon il ya 6
union il ya c'est derrière anne hidalgo
est ce que vous avez lu l'interview de
bernard cazeneuve
qui dit alors je le cite pendant cinq
ans le travail de fond n'a pas été fait
est ce que c'est vrai les socialistes
n'était-il pas finalement pas assez près
pour cette présidentielle en effet nous
n'avons pas été assez près mais nous
avons tous une responsabilité collective
je mens n'exonère pas je n'exonère pas
non plus bernard genin n'exonère
personne nous aurions sable non ce n'est
pas la responsabilité d'olivier fort
quand on est dans une équipe on est là
présent dans les bons et les mauvais
moments ça ne m'empêche pas d'avoir la
lucidité et c'est pourquoi je partage
l'analyse de bernard cazeneuve que nous
n'avons pas assez travaillé mais pour
autant je ne jette pas la vindicte je ne
rends pas responsable une seule personne
parce que dans les moments difficiles on
reste unis on reste sur le bateau et
ensuite on tire avec lucidité les
conclusions de nos erreurs et nous
allons devoir prendre des décisions
douloureuses mais ce qui seront
courageuse et qui seront possibles pour
permettre l'avenir de la gauche
oui ce que vous pouvez me fait réagir
par rapport à la vidéo a émergé d'un des
porte parole de la primaire populaire
qui montre son souhait de d'influer sur
hull sur le cours des élections sous
forme de pression sur les réseaux
sociaux pour empêcher des financements
awards et parrainage est ce que vous est
ce que vous regrettez ce que ça bouge
choc cette vidéo oui il me choque
surtout c'est la déception parce que moi
cette primaire populaire il ya de ça un
mois et demi j'avais signé une tribune
comme quoi j'étais favorable ce qui est
une primaire populaire mais aujourd'hui
c'est plus une primaire il n'y a pas de
présentation de projets ces votes juste
sur des personnalités et c'est un
classement exactement donc c'est cet
espoir qui est né et qui le cet espoir a
demandé une forte mobilisation a permis
une forte mobilisation et bien en fait
ils débouchent sur un projet qui n'est
pas sérieux avec une vidéo voilà qui est
complètement décrédibilisée pour la
primaire donc c'est un regret et je
comprends tout à fait que anne hidalgo
et d'autres disent mais nous ne pouvons
pas participer et nous ne pouvons pas
validé ce procès ce qui n'est pas
sérieux donc je ne reconnaîtraient pas
le résultat de cette primaire mais parce
que ce n'est pas une primaire il n'y a
pas de projet on va voter sur des
personnalités de sûreté ne le connais
pas du tout j'ai jamais je les ai jamais
vus et en plus surtout qu'on n'est pas
le projet on parle de la présidence de
la république française c'est à dire on
va voter pour des visages sans connaître
le projet de société pour les françaises
et les français tout cela n'est pas
sérieux et cette vidéo a été terrible
elle est terrible pour la démocratie
parce qu elle décrédibilise
phénomène citoyens qui auraient pu être
tout à fait qualitatif est tout à fait
respectable juste un élément pour
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur le
ps il va falloir remettre les choses à
plat à l'issue de cette présidentielle
prendre des décisions lesquels pour vous
il va falloir prendre des décisions sur
un travail beaucoup plus collectif sur
un projet de société qui soit clairement
définie chacun et chacune connais mon
projet de société c'est une république
forte avec aucun compromis par rapport
au communautarisme c'est concilier
économie écologie et surtout c'est faire
de l'éducation une absolue priorité pour
la lutte contre le déterminisme social
mais aussi pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui nos entreprises leurs
premiers besoins c'est pas la baisse des
impôts c'est la question des compétences
mais l'impression que vous avez déjà
l'échec de la gauche non je n'attaque
jamais les chèques mais je suis une
combattante et je suis lucide nous avons
un gros travail pour pouvoir redonner
confiance aux électeurs à la gauche
avoir une visibilité je continue à
travailler derrière anne hidalgo mais je
le dis très clairement nous devrons être
beaucoup plus lucide et je serai lucide
je serai force de proposition dans tous
les cas fidèle aux valeurs socialistes
mais pour cette démo social-démocratie
cette social écologique est absolument
indispensable pour réduire les
inégalités et répondre à l'urgence
climatique rendez vous du 27
merci d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]